قال مدير الاستخبارات الخارجيه الروسيه
انه بحث مع مدير وكالات الاستخبارات
الامريكيه قضايا الامن النووي في حين اكدت
الخارجيه الروسيه عدم اعتزال موسكو
المشاركه في اجتماعات معاهده ستارت
الجديده النوويه بسبب تزويد واشنطيف
بالاسلحه من جانبها رجح الفاكون ان تضاعف
الصين مخزونها النووي ثلاث مرات خلال 13
عاما وهو ما نفته بيجن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا وننا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله تاكيد موسكو
بحثها قضايا الامن النووي على المستوى
الاستخبارين مع واشنطن بالتزامن مع تجديد
رفضها الانخراط في اجتماعات معاهده ستارت
الجديده النبويه وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان يؤثر
ربه موسكو تعاونها النووي مع الولايات
المتحده بدعم واشنطن العسكري لقياس وكيف
سيؤثر الجدل النووي على مسار الحرب في
اوكرانيا وما مدى خطوره التعثر التعاون
النووي بين واشنطن و موسكو في ضوئي ترجيح
البنتاجون مضاعفه الرجيم مخزونها من
الرؤوس النوويه ثلاثه مرات في الفتره
المقبله
[موسيقى]
في خض امي تكهنات بشان مصير التعاون
النووي بين موسكو واشنطن بعد تعليق روسيا
مشاركتها في اجتماعات معاهده ستارت
الجديده لاداره المخزون النووي للبلدين
قال مدير الاستخبارات الخارجيه الروسيه
انه بحث مع مديري وكاله الاستخبارات
الامريكيه قضايا الامن النووي واوكرانيا
حديث المسؤول الروسي لم يرقى لتبديد
المخاوف في هذا الشان لكونه مع تجديد
موسكو على اللسان المتحدثه باسم وزاره
الخارجيتها ماريا زخرفه ان روسيا لا تعتزم
مناقشه معاهده ستارت الجديده مع الولايات
المتحده بينما تزود واشنطن امتياز
بالاسلحه وقالت زخرفه ان واشنطن تعتزم
تزويد كياف بمزيد من الاسلحه وتحرضها على
اراقه مزيد من الدماء وتخصص الاموال لما
وصفته بالانشطه المتطرفه التي يشرف عليها
ناس غير متوازينين
وتسائلت زخرفه كيف سيجلس الروس مع هؤلاء
الى طاوله واحده لمناقشه قضايا الامن بما
فيها تلك التي تصب في مصلحتهم وشددت زخرفه
على ان موسكوت تقيم بل تقيم عاليا معاهده
ستارت التي تلبي مصالح كل من روسيا
والولايات المتحده مشدده على ضروره توفير
ظروف مناسبه لمناقشتها
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور
العلاقات الدوليه والمحلل السياسي مرحبا
بكم
ماذا يعني ان تؤجل موسكو المحادثات مع
الولايات المتحده في ايطاليا معاهده ستارت
الجديده ومع ذلك يقوم المسؤولون
الاستخباريون في البلدين بمناقشه الملف
النووي
ان ممثلي البلدين وبشكل خاص رؤساء رايسيه
الرئيسيه
مصلحه حتى الاستخبارات في البلدين يناقشان
الفقره عدم
عدم
الحصول
نوويه مفاجاه
واللذلك امر لا تريد لا لا واشنطن ولا
موسكو وبالتالي هذا هو السبب الرئيسي لهذه
التقاء هذين السدين
مؤخرا اما فيما يتعلق الجزء الاول
روسيا تاجلت الناقشات اعتقد ان السبب ان
اسكت يعني جدول مواصله هذه مناقشات الظروف
الحاليه
ما رايك دكتور كيمبل هل هناك رسائل
متناقضه هنا ام اييي رسائل مستقيمه تريد
موسكو ان ترسلها باتجاه الولايات المتحده
ان تقوم بالغاء مساهمتها في هذا الاجتماع
هذا موجوده منذ 2010 ولا التي تحدد همم
التعداد من الرؤوس النوويه وهذا وهذا في
مصلحه روسيا والمصلحه المتحده استمرار
التنفيذ هذه المعاهده وروسيا قالت انها
تريد الاستماع
التاخير هذا الاجتماع وربطها معاهده جديده
مع حرب الاوكرانيا
الولايات المتحده انت تتوقف عن تسريحه
اوكرانيا اللي تسافر عن نفسها ضد العدوان
الروسي فامل ان روسيا ستات ستغير موقفها
واعتقل ان هذا دليل على ان هناك
اضطراب او ارتباك في لدى الحكومه الروسيه
حول كيفيه التعامل مع الموضوع وكيفيه
محاوله التاثير على علاقات اخرى على
معاهدات الاتفاقيه اخرى لمحاوله تغيير
التوازن العسكري في حربيه
لكن كيف وجدت رغم تاجيل ااا ااا المحادثات
في اطار اتفاقيه ستارت بين موسكو واشنطن
كيف وجدت ان يقوم مسؤولوه الاستخبارات في
البلدين
بحفي قضايا الامن النووي
الصحيح
الاخر
بالتطبيق وتنفيذ اتفاقيه السيطره على
السلاح النووي التي يغتسل لها الطرفان لحد
الان وبالتالي اعتقد انه هذا امر مؤسف
وايضا موقف متناقص ان روسيا تحاول ان تربط
مناقشاتها المستقبليه
الجديده همم
من دعم الولايات المتحده شكرا يا ودف
الدفاع عن نفسه ضد العدوان الروسي
عندما تربط روسيا العوده الى
حافات مع الولايات المتحده
بتسليح الولايات المتحده للطرف الاوكرانيه
عمليا ماذا تريد موسكو
البازيشن
وقد اعلن ذلك مؤخرا على لسان
المتحدث باسم الكربلائي السيد ديسكو
بانه وبسبب جزئيا بسبب
الموقف الامريكي في الحرب الحرب
الاوكرانيه
فان العلاقات بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
في درجه سلبيه كما كانت في العقود هذه
اولا وثانيا وقد اعلن ذلك المتحدث الرسمي
باسم زهره
الروسيه بان سبب تاجيل هذه الناقشات وانا
اؤكد ليس ان روسيا
انت انت
اهتمامهم وصلت هذا الموضوع الاقل ان لا
مهتم مواصله المحادثات ولكن فقط تقوم
بتاجيل هذه الاجتماعات اللي هو كما قالت
المتحدثه فانا مفعل ذلك تدهور العلاقات
بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده
الولايات المتحده لكياز ماذا تريد عمليه
موسكو في هذا الاطار ومعلومه ان يعني جل
السلاح المطلوب هو سلاح للدفاع عن النفس
يعني اوكرانيا تريد ان تدافع عن نفسها في
اطار او ردا على هذا الهجوم الروسي
والاكشن
روسيا تنظر الامر بشكل مختلف فما تراه
روسيا انهم منذلا انقلاب الذي حصل في 2014
والذي راعته واشنطن وقد اعترفت بذلك بدات
الولايات المتحده بجعل اوكرانيا جزء مخططه
كبيره اللي رد على روسيا
قبل ثمان سنوات بدات الحرب داخل اوكرانيا
بين اوكرانيا والجمهورتين المفصليتين
وبالتالي تقوم به روسيا في اوكرانيا ايقاف
هذه الحرب الاهليه ولكن لانه الولايات
المتحده اظهرت بانها الغيبه مهتمه ولا
تريد ايقاف هذه الحرب بل لان ترى ان ذلك
مريحا لها جيدا ان الشعب الروسي من جانبيه
الحدود
اقتناء بعضهما الاخر وهم يتمنون استمرار
هذا القتال لاطول فتره ممكنه لان ذلك يصير
سجعل روسيا اضعف من وجهه نظرها ما تريده
موسكو اذا هو تتوقف الولايات المتحده من
مشاركه الكبيره في هذه الحرب لن نلاقي
الشيء عام داخل روسيا ذلك وهذا لغايه ان
روسيا او الروس يعتبرون روسيا والولايات
المتحده والغرب
ضد روسيا على الجبهه الاوكرانيه
وعلى جبهات الاخرى اقتصاديه حرب اعلاميه
وما الا ذلك
شرحها لنا السيد اليكساندر بورنو كيف يتم
التعامل معها في واشنطن
ان كانت هناك اولويه لدى الولايات المتحده
على الابقاء على المحادثات بين الطرفين في
اطار نيو ستارت
بالحرب
ان الولايات المتحده واوروبا واعظم دول
العالم يدعمون زياده اوكرانيا ضد العدوان
الروسي روسيا ترى الامر بشكل مختلف نعم
ولكن
حول حرب فان من مصلحه واشنطن مصلحه
والمصلحه العالم كله ان هاتين الحكوميتين
همم
اداره اكثر انواع الاسلحه خطره في العالم
وهي الاستحقا او الترسانه النوويه من غير
المسؤول من روسيا ان تقطع الاتصالات
هذه الخطيره من المهم جدا اذا ان الرئيس
بوتين وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه يعودان الى
الواقع
ويوافقون على همم الاجتماع الولايات
المتحده للتنفيذ هذه المعاهده المهمه وبده
بنعم بعمليه التفاوض للاتفاقيه والمعاهده
الجديده لان هذه الحاليه ستنتهي مفعولها
في 2026 وبالتالي الامام المهمه للطرفين
ان يبداوا يبدا باتفاق حول اتفاقيه جديده
ومتالي روسيا ان تفعل ذلك حقا فعليها ان
تعمل بطريقه مهنيه وتوافق على اللقاء
الامريكان
امس التصريح الامريكي بانه همم لا سلاح
بيتريوت للطرف الاوكراني كما يطلب
الاوكرانيون في ايطار يمكن ادراج هذا الاء
يدرج هذا ايضا في اطار التحسب او الحسابات
الامريكيه
لمزيد من التدهور مع موسكو
هذا هذا نعم هذه ملاحظه في غايه الاهميه
الولايات المتحده كانت دقيقه وحريصه جدا
في تزويد اوكرانيا فقط باسلحه دفاعيه ولا
تقدم لافانيا انواع من الاسلحه او
الصواريخ التي يمكن استخدامها
روسيا الرئيس بوتين بشكل كبير وهو يشعر
كبير حول تصعيد هذه الحرب والرئيس لا يريد
ان يرق قوات النيته وقوته
مواجهه مباشره
لان ذلك بمرور الوقت سيؤدي به اوروبا
انواع الاخرى اكثر فتكا من الاسلحه وذلك
يؤذي لا تسعدني اكثر من مرور الزمن اذا
على روسيا
كيف يقرا في موسكو التوجه الذي جرى
التعبير عن في قمه النيتو لناحيه التسليح
ولسيا ما اتحدث هنا عن الموقف الامريكي
ثري اذنك
داخل اراضي الروسيه وتقتل الناس التقويم
اليوميه وتدمر المنازل والولد المدنيه
وبالتالي هذه نقطه والنقطه الاخرى اللي ما
قاله قليل حول
كيف ان الايات المتحده تحاول ان تدير هذه
الحرب
لهذا يعني فعلا
تدير الحرب هي ان هذه الحرب
حقيقيه
[موسيقى]
لاوكرانيا في هذه المرحله كما يطلب
المسؤولون الاوكرانيون
كيف وجدت كيف وجدت سيد اليكساندر ال ال
الموقف الامريكي الذي يقول ان لا سلاح
بيتريوت للطرف الاوكراني حاليا في هذه
المرحله كما يطلب الاوكرانيون المسؤولون
الاوكرانيون
وكما قلت فعلا
انه واشنطن هي
هي من يقاتل هذه الحرب في هذه الحرب ضد
روسيا وسيبعثون باكثر قدر الاسلحه
المطلوبه للمواصله هذه الحرب
المتحده تزامنا مع ترجي وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه البنتاجون ان يرتفع مخزون الصين
من الرؤوس الحربيه النوويه باكثر من ثلاثه
اضعاف خلال العقد المقبل من حوالي 400
حاليا الى 10500 بحلول عام 2035 وقال
البنتاجون في تقريره السنوي الى الكونجرس
حول البناء العسكري الصينيه الطموح ان
بيجين توسع عدد من الصوت توصيل الاسلحه
النوويه البريه والبحريه والجويه وتنشئ
البنيه التحتيه اللازمه لذلك من جانبها
نفت الصين ردا على حديث البنتاجون ان تكون
السياستها النوويه تندرج تحت اي نوع من
سباق التسلق اضافت الصين ان سياستها
النوويه للدفاع عن النفس ونها ملتزمه
بسياسه عدم البدء باستخدام الاسلحه
النوويه
سيد قور نوفا من موسكو كيف تجد هذا
التقييم للفنتاغون بان الصين ستقوم
بمضاعفه الرؤوس النوويه خلال العقد المقبل
النوويه وهذا وهذا الامر طبيعي طبعا لان
الصينه
الاقتصاد رقم واحد في العالم
وبالنسبه فان الصين كانت واحده من المشاكل
التي في مساله مواصله همم
النقاشات والمحادثات في اتفاقيه همم
ان هذه اتفاقيه بين روسيا وولايات المتحده
فلو الضمه
معاهده مختلفه
عن استمراريه المعاهده السابقه البدء بعمل
معاهده تمام جديده تماما وما يريده
الامريكان
حقا اليوم ولما يهتمون بهذه الدرجه في
المفاوضات هذه لانه بالاستخدام
في اوكرانيا للتغيير المعاهده الحاليه
بشكل يناسب مصالحهم ويتناسب مع يريدونه
اكثر ما كان الوضع السائقا وروسيا لا تقول
ذلك في ايطار يمكن وضع هذا الاعلان ل201
لزياده الرؤوس النوويه خلال العقد المقبل
ت بانها تريد زياده عدد
النوويه التي لديها حاليا 300 وقد يرتفع
العدد في العقد القادم هذا وما قال له
التقرير تنتقمون همم ولكن هذا امر ليس
حتميه ان تكون الصين بزياده النوويه فلو
كان بهذا الحجم الكبير بقدر الترسانه
الروسيه والامريكيه وما هو مهم علينا ان
تذكر ذلك
اسلحه بين الولايات المتحده روسيا عمر مهم
جدا
لجعل
العالم والعلاقات خطره
استقرارا تنبؤ والا فانه متحده في حاله
منافسه حاليا لابد ان يدخل المحاضرات
المنطقيه لتقليل المخاطر النوويه ومنع
حصول السباق النووي الكبير انا اعمل في
هذا المجال مثل 30 سنه وهذه استراتيجيه
ثبت صحتها وهي لصالح جميع الدول
وكل عالم ينبغي ان يشعر بقلق حولها هذا
الموضوع ايضا لان اي نزاع النووي بينها
هذه الدول النوويه ليس الخطر عليه فقط على
العالم كلهم
العلاقات الدوليه والمحلل السياسي ضيفنا
من موسكو مشاهدينا الى هنا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
لمتابعتكم الينا»
[موسيقى]